weird
or cut we're gonna do weird first and
after that we're gonna do cut cool
you asked for it
oh this [ __ ] god damn
ah today you woke up into his mind hey
man you came in my inbox i'm just
so this is the one that i have i met him
in 2014 but he wasn't on the market yet
so in 2016 he was on the market and i
decided to see if it was a good
investment for me however the timing
wasn't really right so it wasn't until
the beginning of 2018
that i purchased this one i beg your
pardon
i beg your pardon
[ __ ]
i don't know what kind of weird
alternate version of django unchained
this [ __ ] is
okay
but seeing this [ __ ] made me respect
jordan peel a little bit more
this dead ass looks like this scene from
get out this [ __ ] in the video
is the reason why i get a lot of [ __ ]
[ __ ] from black women
they think i'm him
this is what they think
this what they think is going on what am
i looking at so i get a lot of [ __ ] i
hate to see [ __ ] like that i hate it one
thing that i love about this one is he
can literally do anything fix anything
if he doesn't know how to do something
he will learn that day
and that and then them two [ __ ]
are gonna come out with a statement with
oh we're sorry it was just comedy we're
just man you guys are so dumb just so
[ __ ] dumb
so [ __ ] done but whatever
what do you want me to say what do you
want me to say
it's people and social media yo the [ __ ]
that [ __ ] will do for mediocre [ __ ]
is crazy yup and i mean look at him
but one bad thing one con about this
model is he's taking a little bit longer
than usual to upgrade to fiance mode
so
hopefully soon we'll upgrade to fiance
mode but until then this is my boyfriend
is this is this a trend is it like a
trend that we're doing
on tick tock is that what it is that's a
trend
show me your my and they didn't
understand the undertones that would've
gonna come that's not even a racial
thing it's not even a racial thing they
didn't because they don't see color
right
stupid ass they didn't even see the
undertone in that they didn't see what
they looked like whatever none that so
you believe you me
these [ __ ] are so
listen no no point no pun intended these
[ __ ] are so tone deaf
i have never said this on this channel
but i'm going to say today go ahead
too much [ __ ] mayonnaise because
that's what this is
way too much i i
say it
say it
these were these [ __ ] at this
point it was not even racial you guys it
was just i was just talking about my
boyfriend not once were not one that we
imply the color and everything and stuff
i get that that that's what they're
gonna come out with
trust
trust i'm not even saying you gotta be
woke you gotta be all this black stuff
you know i mean do interracial do
whatever you want
but i couldn't imagine getting myself a
chinese girlfriend being like this is my
ching chang chong chong ching tong you
didn't even go there she didn't even go
there she didn't you don't have to
that's the thing you don't have to do
that you don't have to go you don't have
to do that
and she didn't you're missing the point
you don't have to do all those racial
slur there was nothing racial
technically in what they said
but a picture is a thousand words that's
the thing okay maybe she dressed up as a
kung fu master and started doing [ __ ]
tai chi it's not even it's not even it's
not even that
you don't have to do that i'm confused i
don't know what you're talking about i'm
telling you this
there was nothing in what she said
all right and what she said
technically
there was nothing racially connected you
close your eyes you're like what it's
still weird you know what i mean it's
when you see the picture you don't have
to go ching chong chong ching you don't
have to see i got this
you don't have to see i got this bag i
don't have you don't have to go there
okay
just the presentation
of i got that buying making it sound
like you bought a person
is wrong off the bat
then you got the visuals with your
stupid ass you don't have to change
nothing she can't come to the cookout
neither can you oh no no no no there's a
rap after that i'm sorry i'm sorry no
they're not i mean listen i'd rather
will smith slap my brother on [ __ ]
national television then you bring home
a girl who did that on tick tock i'm
sorry hey imagine imagine i do imagine
imagine imagine you do a cookout at your
mom's place
and this dude's your friend and they
show up and your mom recognize them for
that video what's the discussion you're
gonna have with your mom after that i'm
gonna look her dead in the eyes and say
mom do you identify as black because
that's gonna be relevant to this
conversation
listen hey some dudes really want [ __ ]
man well don't tell me
huh some people are just blinded by
[ __ ]
i mean at least just do this [ __ ] in the
bedroom
you know what i mean keep it private
gee you want to do real weird kink play
i ain't mad at it it's not even that's
your product but but this
is how we see it these [ __ ]
don't see it's obvious to us these
[ __ ] don't even see it if you
want to be they're gonna come out trust
me we could do a part two yeah they're
gonna do an
apology you can put on shackles
if you want to get whipped
and called the n-word within i don't
even care
when you post this [ __ ] online like how
am i supposed to look at you you posted
this [ __ ] with a big old smile on your
face like [ __ ] need to see this i'm so
proud that's an l
that's an l the letter hasn't been
invented i could listen i'm not even
involved in my ancestors like yo slap
this [ __ ] that's how crazy this is
but hey man listen i i genuinely think
like there's just some white women out
there who look at these like
like physical specimens that they can
turn into their little boy toys or
whatever and there's some dudes who like
for whatever brain issues they got like
or like heritage or cultural like issues
that they've inherited they like that
[ __ ] yeah i mean if it's a white woman
they'll let them do anything that's just
been my observation yeah that's been my
observation but maybe i'll disagree
maybe you guys didn't see it as deep as
i did or he did
but that's [ __ ] weird
that's [ __ ]
weird
stranger things weird
what
alfred is [ __ ] oh i think you look at me
like more things so that's like well
[ __ ] calm down
glad i didn't go there but
it really is that
but
listen this is the only time where i'm
like uncle ruckus we need you yeah yeah
yeah yeah cause there's some black folks
you need to hear that the the the
superhero wait oh why no [ __ ] over
here like
for him
yeah get him out yeah
absolutely jesus but actually uncle
ruckus would like to be in that position
yes
no relation anyways let us know what you
guys think all
right no